now if you've seen my YouTube videos
before you'll see me making money
viewing houses out on the road meeting
people negotiating I can't do that from
home however I have found a way whereby
you can make money from home with a
laptop with a phone and I'm going to
show you exactly how I made 3600 pounds
from scratch with a laptop on the phone
and bought a house using practically no
money from home from scratch I don't
know if it's gonna work I'm just gonna
vlog it and document it exactly raw as
it is as I go you might think it's a
terrible time right now to invest in
property because the market is crashing
my strategy is going to be deal sourcing
deal packaging and it's going to be
Lease Option agreements if I found a
list of properties that will motivate it
to sell but how do you find them right
now I can't go out networking I can't
know a few properties what I'm thinking
is this online crazy thing about the
computer who's it knows everything about
you this computer knows so much about me
my lights my interests which is scary
but as a marketer it's not scary it's
exciting I've nothing I can't leave the
house on my computer and there's a
campaign name this is gonna be for
motivated sellers now I think Doncaster
could be good oh my goodness look at
these investors from that ad and I had
79 applications for property I've got a
lot of them email me back saying what
kind of properties are looking for
ideally a 4 or 5 better HMO in Liverpool
so this Wales property is one for 69
thousand and 59 my fifth day I mean with
the seller direct the seller has sent me
a survey with builders quotes at that
price it's a steal
I'm gonna be passing this on for a fee
and then the money that I get I'm gonna
use that to put two wars on the shocking
agreement BRR probably deal in South
Wales no stub do two that's going out to
324 property investors he's getting
quite a lot of response now so I made it
very clear how to respond I mean some
people are just saying whatever in the
car more details but I'm interested I
have the funds and I'm interested and
with a little bit of luck oh yeah mm Wow
how you doing
I think I sent you over the property
details of the buyer refurbish refinance
in South Wales yesterday fantastic
that's great news what I'll do I will
send you over an invoice for three
thousand pound plus VHA all right three
thousand pounds three thousand pounds so
she paid the money I'm working on a
lease option agreement deal and I'm only
like a week into this now this one looks
it very interested because it says
ideally looking to sell but would
consider renting I tell you what I will
drop my friend Joe email I reckon I'm
gonna get that lease option agreement I
really have a good feeling so I sent Joe
over an email of a formal offer on lease
option agreement subject to the survey
he responded from questions seemed kind
of happy said he was going to speak to
his solicitor so I sent him over a
memorandum of understanding heads of
terms absolutely credible news the only
if I made three thousand six hundred
pounds and deal selling but this is the
heads of terms to the lease option
agreement signed with Joe so Joe I
freaking love this is the time when we
need to stand together we need to be
positive and we remember that this is
possible listen guys if you enjoyed the
content please do smash the like button
also don't forget to subscribe to the
channel
I've put together a playlist of all
about lease option agreement so if
you're thinking what did he do exactly
then you should check out this playlist
right here and see how you can buy
properties using little non of your own
moment also if you want to package and
sell deals making money from properties
that you do not even own from home then
check out this playlist up here and
there's a ton of content there also you
can subscribe right here do it subscribe
spread the love spread the positivity
I'll see the next video peace out lock
down property challenge complete now
it's your turn and I'll be helping you
do that